me gustaría darte la bienvenida a
biología en khan academy y como
seguramente ya sabes biología es el
estudio de la vida y la verdad no me
puedo imaginar que haya algo más
interesante que el estudio de la vida
pero ahora cuando me refiero a la vida
no me refiero únicamente a nosotros los
humanos sino también a las plantas y las
bacterias y a un montón de seres vivos y
la verdad es que sí es fascinante cómo
puede ser que nosotros empezamos como
moléculas inanimadas y átomos y bueno
por ejemplo aquí tenemos una molécula de
adn como le hacemos para empezar con
cosas como esta y obtener toda la
complejidad que es un ser vivo y bueno
tal vez en estos momentos tú quieras
preguntar bueno qué es lo que hace que
un ser sea un ser vivo bueno pues los
seres vivos transforman la energía de
una forma a otra utilizan esa energía
para crecer usan esa energía para
cambiar y también usan esa energía para
reproducirse
y cada una de éstas en sí es fascinante
como le hacen los seres vivos para hacer
todo esto podemos observar las cosas a
nuestro alrededor
cómo le hacemos nosotros para comernos
un pastel y porque eso nos permite
movernos y pensar y hacer todas las
cosas que hacemos como le hacemos para
obtener esa energía a partir de ese
pastel y de qué forma somos parecidos a
una planta oa un insecto porque la
verdad es que somos inquietantemente
bueno muy extrañamente parecidos a ellos
de hecho hay muchísimas cosas que
tenemos en común con los insectos las
plantas las bacterias el árbol que está
afuera de tu casa y la abeja que está
sumando por ahí cerca tenemos mucho más
en común con todos esos seres vivos de
lo que te das cuenta incluso tenemos
muchas cosas en común con las bacterias
aunque a las bacterias solo las podamos
ver a un nivel microscópico y bueno una
muy buena parte de algo que nosotros le
llamamos nosotros de hecho son bacterias
así es que tenemos todas estas preguntas
fascinantes por ejemplo cómo surgió la
vida y a lo largo de este curso vas a
poder ver en biología en khan academy
que vamos a resolver todo este tipo de
preguntas fundamentales fascinantes
vamos a estar pensando en cosas como la
energía y el rol de la energía en la
vida también vamos a pensar en moléculas
muy importantes para la biología como el
adn y su rol en la reproducción de los
seres vivos y en contener toda la
información y también vamos a estudiar a
las células las cuales son los bloques
de construcción de la vida y cómo vamos
a ver incluso aunque veamos a las
células como estas cosas súper súper
súper pequeñas son increíblemente
complejas y de hecho si las comparamos a
una escala atómica en realidad son
bastante grandes por ejemplo aquí este
fondo azul todo este fondo azul es la
superficie de un leucocito de una célula
del sistema inmunológico
y lo que estamos viendo por aquí estas
cosas amarillas son virus vih saliendo
de nuestras células del sistema
inmunológico así es que incluso aunque
nos estemos imaginando a las células
como estas cosas super pequeñas son
increíblemente complejas y bueno incluso
los virus son estas cosas fascinantes
que están justo en el límite entre seres
seres vivos y no definitivamente se
reproducen y evolucionan pero no
necesariamente tienen un metabolismo y
vamos a aprender muchísimo acerca de eso
los virus no necesariamente utilizan
energía y crecen de la misma forma que
nosotros asociamos con la vida y luego
también tenemos otra pregunta que es
probablemente una de las preguntas más
grandes de la historia
cómo surgió la vida también vamos a
estudiar eso mientras estudiamos la
evolución y la selección natural
así es que bienvenido a la sección de
biología de khan academy
me parece que vas a encontrar que esta
es una ciencia fascinante y bueno
seguramente te vas a dar cuenta de que
la biología es en muchos sentidos la más
compleja de las ciencias y en muchos
sentidos es la ciencia a la que menos
entendemos es una ciencia que está
construida sobre la química la cual a su
vez está construida sobre la física la
cual también está construida sobre las
matemáticas y la biología honestamente
en los últimos 100 años apenas estamos
empezando a rascar la superficie de lo
que podemos llegar a entender pero lo
que es realmente muy interesante es
hacia dónde está yendo el campo de la
biología porque conforme empecemos a
entender cosas a un nivel más profundo a
un nivel molecular
vamos a empezar a pensar en cómo podemos
hacer ingeniería biológica o en cómo
podemos influir al mundo a nuestro
alrededor y por supuesto eso va a hacer
que surjan un montón de preguntas super
fascinantes profundas y bueno por
supuesto también unas preguntas éticas
pero bueno ojalá que disfrutes mucho
esta sección la biología en verdad es
una de las materias más fascinantes y
bueno por supuesto no quiero ofender ni
a los químicos ni a los físicos ni a los
matemáticos que están por ahí por
supuesto que también encuentro
fascinantes todas esas otras materias
pero por el momento vamos a contestar o
bueno vamos a intentar empezar a
contestar unas de las preguntas más
fundamentales de nuestra existencia